mes chers compatriotes malgré tous mes
efforts malgré ma détermination je n'ai
pas réussi à vous convaincre les
obstacles mis sur ma route étaient trop
nombreux trop cruel le moment venu la
vérité de cette élection sera écrite
dans l'immédiat j'assume mes
responsabilités cette défaite est la
mienne et c'est à moi et à moi seul
qu'il revient de la porter
j'adresse à tous ceux qui ont voté pour
moi à tous ceux qui depuis quatre ans me
soutiennent avec dévouement et avec
courage un message d'amitié et de
reconnaissance je ne les oublierai
jamais
à l'occasion des élections législatives
ils auront la possibilité de faire
entendre la voix de la droite et du
centre ne vous dispersez pas restez unis
rester déterminé croyez-moi votre force
va compter la France en a besoin
en attendant il nous faut choisir ce
qu'il y a de préférable pour notre pays
je ne le fais pas de gaieté de coeur
mais l'abstention n'est pas dans mes
gènes surtout lorsqu'un parti extrémiste
s'approche du pouvoir
le Front national
ce parti créé par Jean-Marie Le Pen à
une histoire qui est connue pour sa
violence et pour son intolérance son
programme économique et social mènerait
notre pays à la faillite et à ce chaos
il faudrait ajouter le chaos européen
avec la sortie de l'euro je vous
l'assure
l'extrémisme ne peut qu'apporter malheur
et division à la France
dès lors il n'y a pas d'autre choix que
de voter contre l'extrême droite je
voterai donc en faveur d'Emmanuel Macron
j'estime
j'estime de mon devoir de vous le dire
avec franchise et il vous revient
maintenant en conscience de réfléchir à
ce qu'il y a de mieux pour votre pays et
pour vos enfants
mon rêve pour nos enfants c'est qu'ils
puissent vivre dans un pays libre
fraternel et fier de ses valeurs un pays
débarrassé de la hantise du déclin un
pays où toutes les promesses de notre
devise républicaine puisse être
réalisées c'était mon ambition c'était
mon projet c'était mon rêve ce rêve est
en chacun d'entre vous il revient de
vous battre et de vous unir pour le
concrétiser
l'avenir de la France est d'abord dans
vos mains j'ai confiance en vous et je
me permets en cet instant de vous dire
que je suis fier d'être l'un des vôtres
un Français qui aime son pays et qui
croira toujours en lui vive la France
vive la république